[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality and
best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety
is my co-host today here on the air we
have been teaching you
for approaching 30 years to
live like no one else
so that later you can live and give
like no one else there's only three
things you can do with money you can
spend it on yourself and enjoy it and
you should
you can invest it and you should
and you can be outrageously generous
and when you do that you'll find it is
the highest and best use of money
it is the use of money that will give
you the most joy
on the eve of christmas eve it is a dave
ramsey show tradition
to take calls from those of you who have
enjoyed
generosity you have a great generosity
story
god was so generous that he sent his
only son
to pay our debts our sin and that's what
we're celebrating here it's called
christmas
mary christmas
and so we want to hear your generosity
stories call us right now at
825-5225 if you've been on the receiving
end of generosity or on the giving end
of
generosity and it's a great story and it
will inspire the rest of us
to be more generous that's what we want
to hear for the next several hours
open phones again triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and from a mental
health perspective when people
give it takes their eyes off themselves
and a whole lot of neurosis
is really comes down to being selfish
they evaporate
when you've when you find it within
yourself to do something for other
people you get outside of your own head
and your own heart
you will find that the things that ail
you just simply poof like a vapor
yeah and there's something magical and
life-giving about
being and living for other people very
difficult
to be depressed when you're out
registering almost impossible when
you're honest it activates a whole
different
counter set of chemicals in the body uh
in the spirit
uh and in the emotions right it really
does looking for
ways that you can support and help other
people which gives you purpose
so if case you hadn't noticed 2020
pretty much sucked
that's the rumor so what we're going to
do is we're going to give our way out of
it
so that we all have a little bit of a
better attitude yeah i like that plan
there we go
we're going to give so this is the
annual giving show our last live show
of the season because uh we don't work
between christmas and new year's i'm
going out with my family to a warm place
somewhere
and uh we'll be back in the first week
of january doing the show again so in
the meantime you'll have
this to remember these giving stories
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five
brianna is in austin texas to start us
off tell us about giving brianna
hi dave and dr d i love you guys so much
merry christmas merry christmas to you
we love you thanks
i'm so blessed to be talking with y'all
i'm going to share my given story um so
my husband ralph and i are actually on
the receiving end
of the biggest blessing of our lives and
it's funny dave in october
when we received this blessing i
actually called in and spoke with you to
get some guidance so you might remember
me
so a little background ralph and i have
been married three years and he has two
older sons
um being a mom has been a dream of mine
i've wanted to
be pregnant and experience motherhood my
entire life
after we got married we tried having a
baby and a year into it nothing
so we saw a fertility doctor and at that
point
after doing testing they said look
brianna based on your age
and what's going on you're gonna have to
do ivf
so obviously um that's a very expensive
procedure and at the time dave
we didn't know you so we were over the
top in
consumer debt like coming out of our
ears just it was so stressful
so the doctor came in and gave us a
little price list and he says well you
guys can finance it
20 to 25 000 we have finance options
for a split second we said maybe we
should and then i said you know what we
can't
so i cried a lot we left the appointment
we never went back
i was so sad and felt so defeated and i
just didn't understand
i didn't understand why this was
happening i got on my knees and i cried
and i prayed to god and i basically just
said you know what god i'm giving it to
you
i trust you and that's that so 2019
october dave
we found you jumped into fpu read the
book
budgeting everything and god willing
we've been paid
we've paid off almost 30 000 in this
last year wow
yes so blessed so here we are in 2020
october we celebrated my birthday we
went to california to visit friends and
family
and dave and john a dear friend of mine
over 20 years of friendship
um he and his wife have been very
blessed with wealth
and for my birthday they blessed us with
uh
twenty thousand dollars to get ibs wow
i love these people i love these people
brianna you have way better friends than
i do
i'm telling you not only that y'all they
basically
said that if it's more than 20 000 call
them and they'll take care of it
so honestly i've never in my life had a
blessing like that
we came straight home back to austin saw
a new fertility doctor
and we're starting treatments in january
yay
congratulations now you gotta call back
next year and give us the end of this
story okay
i promise i will yeah we have to finish
we have to finish this story out because
this is we're catching this blessing
mid blessing we are and i just want to
say one thing to your listeners dave um
i just want to encourage your listeners
no matter what's going on in life
whether it's money issues the loss of a
loved one marriage issues
no matter what lean on god pray to him
talk to him
he's gonna get you through it honestly
we thought there was no way
and god made a way for this and it was
on his time and we are so blessed and i
just encourage others to just
remember to lean on him testify sister i
like it
so uh you know here's what's interesting
that i think about in this
is that uh you you didn't have this
motivation
but the net result was when you started
getting your act together and we're
worthy of
trust god just redirected some wealthier
way
he did yeah i mean
and while you were living in chaos and
impulse he didn't do it
no matches up with a parable of the
talents those who
manage a little well are given more to
manage and uh wow i love this
well done great story hey thank you for
thank you for calling in with that
that's cool i do remember her call
she was calling she was like freaking
out do i have to put this 20 000 on my
debt snowball
i went absolutely not it was a
designated gift like the nursery gift
you and i got yesterday right
that was 1500 right but uh it's a
designated gift
and um and yeah that's a
that's a place in in a couple's soul
when they're trying to have children
that's special and i know that brianna
is reeling from this extraordinary gift
i would love to hear from the people who
were able to give this oh
yeah that they they they walked step by
step
live disciplined lives were were blessed
and then just
had the ability and then a need came
forward to
literally read reimagine somebody's
family tree
i can imagine this guy sitting there
going you know we got two million
dollars in our 401k let's give him
twenty thousand let's give him two
thousand dollars
i have a baby and have a family
touchdown
good for you guys it's the annual giving
show on the eve of christmas eve
dr john dolone and dave ramsey on the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's the eve of christmas eve which is
our annual giving show dr john dolone
ramsey personality
and author of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety
what it is what it's not and how to get
your life back we're taking your calls
about giving
when you received something or when you
gave something all about
inspiring generosity
and you know sometimes you're supposed
to give on the down low
what the bible says you know rory ryden
doesn't know what the left hand's doing
and
it's you know you're not doing it for
accolades and that kind of thing
but i have discovered that that and
that's how i do the vast majority of our
giving most of the ramsey foundation
family foundation giving or
just dave and sharon giving somebody a
high five with 100 or something we don't
talk about that we just do it and we
don't bring it up
um but occasionally
you need to be a
vocal uh video playing video example
for other people so that they see it and
they feel it
and so like you know the 10 million
dollar debt that we have
that we paid off around here so we did
we've done some publicity on that we put
it out and
it's been on fox business i was on fox
and friends this morning talking about
it and that kind of stuff
and you know the haters are like well
you're not supposed to tell anybody when
you do that
you obviously you're just doing this for
advertising it's like they had gum i
could have bought advertising
cheaper than that's right okay you butt
and so
obviously i didn't do it for that uh i
but but i you know i have to when
somebody says that it does kind of sting
a little and i think well i wonder if i
was doing it wrong motives
but then i remember no we're called to
teach you guys how to handle money
and all of us are called to be an
example to one another to lift each
other up
and so brag a little bit about receiving
or about giving today
to inspire others and to cause it to be
paid forward
i wrestled with that personally for
years and until
i learned that people learn more by
watching you
and that was a signal for me that i got
to be more demonstrative for my kids for
my family for my friends
because that's how they're going to say
oh that's what that looks like right
in the real world and that's how that
feels and here's an example of how you
can do something with leverage
there you go and um you know i've gotten
to sit at
some uh giving symposiums like i went to
this one thing with these guys and
the average net worth in the room was
like a billion i was a wiener in a
steakhouse
right i mean i was not in my league you
know
they wouldn't let me in the parking lot
but those men and women
had different ideas on how to do stuff
on giving that was
really cool yeah and it lit me up and on
my little small scale then i was able to
come back and be motivated by that so
those of you that don't like that we're
trumpeting giving from the rooftops
maybe we need to do that this year
because everybody's been all concerned
about
not giving this year everybody's been
all concerned about
taking this year about divisiveness and
polarization on the racial
issues and the dadgum political disaster
and mask or no mask
and let's just let's just get all mad
let's just spend the whole freaking year
being mad at each other everybody
no not today
this is the eve of christmas eve calm
your butt down
we're talking about generosity and we
want to hear from you triple eight eight
two five
five two two five trent is in phoenix
trent tell us your giving story
dave dr john this is a huge pleasure
this is definitely one of the coolest
things that's ever happened to me
well we're honored you need to get out
more brother yeah you've got to get
better friends my
trent you need way better friends
how can we help man tell us your giving
story
so a few years ago my wife and i were
living in
the middle of the new mexico west texas
oil field
and i had a job i was working for
an excavation company and i was making
the equivalent of minimum wage in the
oil field
and the cost of living out there is
horrendously high we were renting a two
bed
uh one bath i think it was probably
about
oh maybe six or seven hundred square
foot uh
you know four plex and it was 12.50 and
we had to cover utilities on top of that
so add on all the other you know food
and everything else and it was it was
draining more
than we were making and
when i was working at this company this
excavation company i got put
under the tutelage of this crusty
hard old man he was
he was larger than life very physically
imposing guy
but he was very hard very
unkind very ruthless most of the time he
was a notorious
scrooge 365 days a year
unless he was around women in which case
he had charm and charisma at a burn and
he was just the life of the party
um so he took me under his wing and he
taught me how to drive heavy equipment
and stuff like that
and slowly but slowly we became friends
and and he knew how much i was making he
made considerably more than i did
so um a few months later i had left that
company for a job that paid
a couple dollars an hour more and
my wife was working for a pharmacy
that was in town and
he came in there to get his prescription
and he came in and this was right before
christmas and he was wearing a
santa hat and he came in and he started
talking to my wife and he said
how's that boy that you married and she
said well
we're doing good you know we're just
doing what has to be done
and he said well that's just you know
that's good good for you guys
awesome and then he picked up his
prescription and then he had an envelope
in his hands
and he slid it across the desk to her
and he said now you wait until i leave
before you open that merry christmas
merry christmas to everybody and then he
he rushed out the door and uh
i had already resigned that christmas to
be just
horrible and no presence and we're going
to be behind on bills and
and everything and she hurried and
opened up the
up the envelope and uh
she found this really expensive looking
card inside and she opened it up
and uh inside it had in his
his hen scratched writing to mrs j and
that
that guy that she married i hope that
this can make your christmas a little
bit more magical
and uh there was 10 100
bills in the envelope wow
she rushed out to the front door past
everybody that was in line
she got outside and she said it was the
most magical scene she'd ever seen
he got into his truck and he was just
getting out of the parking lot as fast
as he could and she said
i'll call him bill for the sake of the
story she said bill we can't accept this
that's too much
and uh he said santa doesn't take gifts
back
and then he just roared out of there and
uh a lot of people have descriptors of
what santa is to them you know he
you know rides in a sleigh he wears a
suit he
you know gives toys to people for me
at least for that christmas my
descriptors of santa was
he's vulgar he smokes camel wise
he's an alcoholic and he drives the shed
yeah but dude when you're making that
kind of money a thousand dollars might
as well be a hundred thousand dollars
yeah that was a lot of money that was
like changed your whole net worth
yep that's huge man i've been right
there i know exactly how that crap feels
in in west texas speak um that guy you
married
is is um a special language for
my friend that i can't say those words
out loud or i'll just break down and
start crying
[Laughter]
amen i don't know people say that about
me all the time they tell sharon that
guy you married yeah
yeah this is totally different from
tennessee yeah that's definitely what
they tell sheila
sheila and sharon are in that same camp
yeah they get that guy you married
that's exactly right and there's a bit
of an eye roll
yes yeah it's like a sympathy thing that
guy you're married that's exactly the
special group
special groups i love it
well done santa claus [ __ ] cables and
a chevy i love it
got a cigarette hanging out of his lip
roaring off into four-wheel drive
i like it go santa oh ho baby
if you live like no one else later you
can live and
give like no one else
on the eve of christmas eve this is our
annual giving show here on the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
good tidings we bring
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help
trim those expenses and make sure your
family is cared for
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something at a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180 000
worth of bills and got close to 75
discounts chm shared the rest of the
expenses
to see if chm is right for you and your
budget
check out chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
ah
my co-host today dr john deloney ramsey
personality
best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety what it is what it's
not
how to get your life back today's the
eve of christmas eve and the way we
always celebrate that around the dave
ramsey show is
we do a special giving show where we
take your calls and you tell giving
stories
stories about a time you gave or you
received in order to inspire
17 million listeners to greater
generosity
pretty cool on the debt free stage but
with a giving story hillary
is with us live in the lobby from
lakeland
florida hi hillary how are you i'm good
dave how are you better than i deserve
what brings you to nashville
well born and raised actually here in
nashville currently living in florida
i'm here to tell a little bit of a
giving story okay
i want to start that out with saying i
appreciate just a few weeks ago you
sharing a little bit about in one of
your podcasts human trafficking
and actually work in that field and
after that podcast is when they talked
about the giving show and so i actually
wrote in after that and i just
appreciate you sharing um getting the
word out about
about the work that we're doing out here
so um
that led me to our story about giving
and
um a little bit of back story with that
is that i
have a little girl out here running
around like crazy in the lobby
but she's a year and a half now and
while i was pregnant actually had
multiple complications with her with
several several hospital visits that i
was spending
weeks at a time days at a time multiple
times that i just had to be in the
hospital while
i'm pregnant with her and then after
giving birth
she actually had several complications
as well
and so um in december of last year she
was born in september in december of
last year my husband and i
found ourselves getting a bill every day
you know you check that mailbox and it's
supposed to be one of the happiest times
of the year and it was one of the most
stressful times of the year
every time that we would check the
mailbox it was another doctor another
you know another hospital bill another
this another that another hospital you
know all of that and so
at that time it was um stress it was
just stressful all the time
and i'll never forget and it's a family
member of ours
and our giving story begins with him
because we opened the mailbox one day
and for the first time we didn't have
a bill but we actually had just enough
of a check
to cover her hospital stay visit and
in that moment it was like oh okay we
can breathe because for the first time
and if you you know if you've ever had a
child in the hospital you know
when that bill comes it's just this
heavy burden
and to have that little or a lot amount
to cover just enough to be done with
that bill was like
just such a relief on us and and
honestly from then
we were not doing we we did you know
your whole
um everything before we got married but
we were not to actually participating in
it
until kind of that moment and that's
really what i wanted to share today
because he gave us um and then from
there we realized like
okay we gotta honor not only him um but
we gotta honor ourselves
and we have to honor the lord and it
took a couple months and
a few more hospital visits to um really
get our budget under control and kind of
do that whole back and forth thing but
once we got that budget under control
um starting kind of mid-year this year
we've um
on our baby step two and we've paid off
about
twenty thousand two hundred dollars so
far wow
good for you we have a little bit more
to go a lot more to go but
we're super motivated just in you know
honoring what people
are out here to do it's really just to
like bless your lives and to honor your
family
and being able to do that and honor the
lord and that too gave us such an
opportunity to say okay
we got to be out here doing it and so um
we have one more hospital bill
left and then student loans from there
and we'll be done
with our debt and hopefully back here
doing our debt free school i love it
i'm so happy for you yes well done well
done
i appreciate that that's a great story
because there's something about
like you said a child being in the
hospital there's a hopeless
feeling you can't not hopeless not that
you don't hope for the child but it is
helpless absolutely you don't feel like
there's anything you can do you're stuck
absolutely and then the bills are piling
up and you're stuck again
and then this one check breaks them
loose that's a big deal it's one of the
most
um vulnerable places i've ever been in
my life because you just
in the midst of having all of this come
in the mail you're also
trying to take care of her make sure she
has the best care as well
and and so that little bit of relief was
like the thing that
it was like okay this is it and this is
our sign that we have to get on board
and kind of do this we actually i'm
happy to share but just
last week on our anniversary we got an
email stating
negative negative negative negative i
love it and so
um you know i'll say this our since
doing this we're consistently tithing
for the first time in our our
whole marriage and we feel like we're
more of a team than we ever have been
anxieties are lower um which is such a
big thing people think a budget won't do
that to you but it really actually helps
yeah and it's a sense of power yeah
really truly it is so we're grateful for
you
well you too we're happy thank you
congratulations and what a great
great giving story thank you for sharing
that thank you merry christmas merry
christmas
open phones at 825-5225 taking your
giving and or receiving stories rick
and william are in utah hey guys how are
you
hello dave and john it's good to talk to
you merry christmas merry christmas to
you
tell us your giving story hey we wanted
to
call in i wanted to brag on my son
william here for a little bit
he's a junior at desert hills high
school here in st
george and every year desert hills
uh does a fundraiser to benefit or bless
somebody in need in our community and
this year they decided to raise money
for a little girl in a community that
has
leukemia and they were partnering with
make a wish to raise money and uh
benefit
uh give her some benefit that way
and um william saw this and and he
he was thinking about it he's got a
little sister about the same age and
he said you know i've got this money and
uh
he said if somebody uh you know if
my little sister was having some
problems i would hope that somebody
would help help her out
and so he um
you know unbeknownst to us he didn't he
didn't talk to us or anything he just
he just decided he's like i've got 500
bucks i'm going to throw that down and
try to help jim out here so
wow later and ended that but i mean
that's a huge deal for a
16 year old kid to throw 500 bucks into
the fundraiser that way
hey man well i got to tell you as a dad
of
uh three kids that do a lot of giving
and are generous it makes us proud it
makes us stick our chest out doesn't it
no for sure yeah where'd it go
i don't know why we were blessed to have
such a good generous kid like this but
all the beatings paid off
i'll tell you rick kids generous kids
come from generous parents
and that apple hit that tree all the way
down so congratulations to you and i
want you to know
all the the extra tips and the extra
kindness that you showed people over the
years william just absorbed that
and now he is able to take that and
magnify it and
give it to people who he's never met
he's never gonna meet but are gonna be
blessed by nonetheless so good for you
man
hey man william are you there thank you
i'm here hi
brother you are a different kind of what
16 17 year old
i'm 16. when i was 16 500
in my head would have bought me a lot of
things but not a
anonymous gift to a young girl and i
want to tell you brother i'm proud of
you
and you are paving the sidewalks that my
little kids out here
are going to be walking on as they get
older and you are a reason that we can
be optimistic about what the future is
going to look like
young people like you in your hearts so
i'm grateful for you man william your
stud man we're proud of you
well done i love it and uh that's what
happens
um rachel says in the book um smart
money smart kids that more is caught
than taught
they are watching everything moms and
dads very unusual for
you to have us out outlandishly
outrageously generous 16 year old now
you can when they're
a lot of them when they're three are
generous right right but
life knocks it out of them by the time
they're 16 and if they're not seeing mom
and dad model it and 500
for 16 year olds a million bucks right
yeah that's a lot of dates and a lot of
music and a lot of other things that way
to go william what a stud man way to go
rick
proud of both of you very good stuff
that's fun
set the bar man set the bar that's how
it works
it's our annual giving show this is the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh saint nicholas lean your ear this way
don't you tell a single soul
what i'm gonna say
christmas eve is coming soon
now it's our annual giving show dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today
budgeting doesn't have to suck you know
most time when you say budgeting to
people they're
they like flinch like you swung at them
or something
uh you just need a budget that actually
works so you tell your budget what to do
until you get it done and then it tells
you what to do
so the whole thing's voluntary you don't
have to do it so it doesn't have to be
like this onerous thing
however if it actually works it's
probably on every dollar
the world's best budgeting app which is
a ramsey product and is inside of ramsey
plus
see with every dollar you get a plan on
how to spend and save every month and
how to connect your budget with your
bank so
that all your transactions are done boom
boom just like that and you get custom
insights on your spending and here's the
deal when you can visualize what's going
on when you hit
what's going to hit and when you don't
have to wonder
if you have enough to cover your bills
your stress level goes
way down
when you budget way down even if you
have a lot
of bills you can't pay even if you have
too much month left at the end of the
money
when you budget you at least know i got
my food my shelter my clothing my
transportation and your stress level
goes
way down so when you can make a plan for
your money
that's when you start feeling control to
start a free trial of ramsey plus text
the word begin to three three seven
eight nine
that's begin to three three
seven eight nine
gail is with us gail is in jacksonville
florida hi gail welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey dave hey john merry merry christmas
mary mary tell us your giving story
so my husband has 15 nieces and nephews
and every year they have children so
every year we would pick one of them
to buy for for christmas this particular
year we picked
a niece that her husband had left
her because he didn't want to raise
children and she had a two four and six
year old
she was working
and he had decided that drugs was more
important than the children
yeah so me and my husband would go
garage selling um
every weekend and buy the kids clothes
and toys and
try to provide as much as we could to
help her
um i was listening to the radio and they
had a contest
which i entered on her behalf and i had
to do an essay on why i thought
she should get the vehicle and it was
giving a vehicle to somebody in need
she had a vehicle that was barely
getting her back and forth to work
so i did the contest and the day before
the winner was announced they had called
me and told me i was one of the three
runner-ups
and that if they chose us
would we how would she pay the taxes on
the vehicle
and everything to get the vehicle and i
said well if you
choose her me and my husband will pay
for everything we will make sure
that she even has insurance for six
months so
about the next morning they called and
said they had chose me
and we had reached out i called her job
and spoke to her both
and we had the radio station
go to her job pick her up she had no
idea
where she was going or what was going on
we were at the place where the vehicle
was
they pulled in and she seen me and her
uncle
standing there and she started crying
because we had already been doing so
much they read
the essay to her what i had said about
her
and then as they're reading this essay
they're driving
the van up behind us and
then they said the gift that you have
won is behind you and when she
turned around she we all started crying
she was crying they took
pictures of us i love
it so but it was just
great it was so great and
to say real quick two days ago
i had told i was going shopping to buy
my pastor's wife a gift
me and my husband pulled in to
mcdonald's to get lunch on our way and i
walk in
to the counter and the gentleman in
front of me bought me lunch and he turns
around and he says
god told me to buy y'all lunch and
i thought you know we're headed to get
our pastor's wife a gift
so you know god is just so good and so i
just wanted to share
hey man well thank you so much so fun
it's beautiful it's all around you
it's all around you this generosity
thing but that's a fun one
i mean they pull the car up behind her
and everybody turns around starts crying
i almost start crying when you're
telling it that's great
yeah it was awesome it was a van of all
things and she had a two four and six um
two four and six year old
you know children that she's trying to
provide for and um
took her and got her six months worth of
insurance on the car
we bought her a cell phone um and paid
for that in advance and we just set her
up you know and it was just so
heart feeling and giving is so better
than receiving
amen you know there's just something
about it
a lot more fun and the good news is you
were in a position to do that
yes yes amen amen yes all because thank
you for your plan
we've been listening to you since 2000.
well i didn't know that you did it i'm
proud of you
yeah yeah you got yourself in a position
you know being generous you know
you can have an in great intentions if i
intend to send my wife flowers it
doesn't count
[Laughter]
you know but but you know you got to
really you got to really do it
and so you can have all kinds of great
generous intentions in your little heart
if you don't get yourself positioned to
act on those
then you're not ever going to really get
to see the benefit of that generosity
and you guys did gail i'm proud of you
well done very well done that's cool
that's so cool
that's that's fine because that i mean
it's a that's a
a letter writing exercise that paid off
real big and then also the cell phone
and the insurance and all the
knickknacks right that just the taxes
those are game changers for that family
yeah it's amazing absolutely a game
changer beautiful stuff kevin
is with us on our giving show kevin's in
dallas kevin tell us your giving story
hey guys merry christmas so my story
begins back in 2013 i had just gotten
out of college
and had been offered an internship at a
church
here in dallas and so i was working
part-time there and
kind of figuring out who i was as an
adult and what i was supposed to do with
my life and
as i was doing ministry i realized that
i felt called to
learn the bible and train for ministry
and so
uh just so happens there's a good
seminary here in dallas called dallas
theological seminary and so
what i did was i felt like i was obeying
god and uh
put all of my savings that i had after
college
into my first semester there so i was
able to pay for that in fall of 2013
but the problem was that was all my
money and i didn't really have much
money
at that time so um i didn't really know
what to do
from there but i felt like i was in the
right place and i remember i was coming
to the end of that fall semester
in 2013 and it was a friday and it was a
friday
that my money for the next semester was
due and if i didn't
pay for next semester i'd drop my
classes and i wouldn't be able to
continue on and i remember praying that
morning
to god and just saying lord i know i
i think i'm in the right place um
i don't have any money and i know i
don't want to go into debt or anything
to do this
uh so hey if you want me here um
you need to help me figure out a way to
pay for this and uh
otherwise you know i'm glad to take some
time off school
and take a load off for a while so
anyways that was that morning that
afternoon
i showed up to my desk and nobody really
knew about this except for a couple
people
who were close to me and my family who
didn't tell anybody but
i show up at my desk and there's an
envelope on my desk
and i'm i'm looking at it going what's
what's that and i open it up
there's no name on it and inside of the
envelope is
three thousand dollars cash unmarked and
um with a with a bible verse on it
that's romans 12
13 that says give to the saints who are
in need
and my bill for that next semester was
just about fifty dollars away from three
thousand dollars so wow
that money uh that money covered my next
semester
and uh i was i'll tell you what i was
floored
and i've been in seminary for about
seven and a half years and i just
graduated about a week ago i wrote my
last paper
i love it well congratulations what a
great story too
don't you wonder who that was i do i
really want to know who that was i
really want to know who it was was it a
professor was it a pastor was it
a parent who who did that that's awesome
that is that's
almost to the dollar man well done well
done
and you just love it when got god's
fingerprints all over it this is a
giving show
on the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
i want him to come clean out a credit
card that he doesn't know about i'm
gonna probably pay
student loans for the rest of my life i
just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey show
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show character
where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money dr john deloney
ramsey personality and author of the
best-selling book redefining anxiety
is my co-host today this is the eve of
christmas eve which can only mean one
thing on the dave ramsey show
our traditional giving show we always do
a giving show as our last broadcast of
the calendar year
heading into christmas because god gave
his only begotten son
hate our debts with it and so we're
going to talk about giving
generosity we teach you to live like no
one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else so if you have a great giving story
you call in and talk to dr john and me
we want to hear your great giving story
it could be when you gave something or
when you receive something but it's
inspiring
to other people to hear great giving
stories as a matter of fact this may be
one of the more popular shows we do
every year so much so that we're tempted
to do them all year but
we reserve them for this special day
stacy is with us in houston texas hi
stacy
welcome to the dave ramsey show tell me
your giving story
hey dave i i actually have a story of
receiving and giving
on september the 17th of 2017 our son
was
killed tragically in a car wreck and
um he was thank you
he was 24 years old and he was married
they were expecting their first
child very soon in fact the baby was
born 12 days after
jacob passed away so in those days that
followed
the vehicle that they had was destroyed
and there was no vehicle for daniella
and the new baby
and our community and jacob's employer
rallied together and donated money to
provide a vehicle for her
um and so we were so blessed as a family
by the generosity of our community
and people that knew jacob and loved
them and knew us and loved us that
we wanted to give back to our community
and we wanted to
do something for the the seniors the
seniors for our high school that were
graduating
so our family has always been
fundraising like for cancer
fundraisers and such so what we decided
to do to honor jacob
and to give back to the community was um
we
made homemade chocolate chip cookies and
my husband fries
uh pork skins and jacob's oldest brother
put together
a flag football tournament that we try
to do annually but this year we were
unable to do
due to the cova crisis um but the first
year that we gave
uh the scholarships we were able to
raise money to give seven
um scholarships totaling fourteen
thousand five hundred dollars
we live in a very small town i know it
said houston but we're actually in buena
texas
oh yeah um so uh that first
like i said the first year we gave 14
500 and this last year
uh we didn't get to have one of our
events so we were a little bit shorter
on funds but we were still able to give
ten thousand dollars
uh to the high school students seven
high school students received a combined
total of ten thousand dollars
wow this fall and we can
plan on continuing to do this as long as
the lord allows us um
we kind of took a break on cooking food
during the kobe crisis but this
christmas
season we decided to try the cookie bake
and
this this cookie bake we raised a
thousand dollars in about a week so we
have a thousand dollars to go into our
scholarship funds
and very fortunately we found out that
our company
that we work for matches um they have a
matching gift
program so my husband and i both work
for the same company and they'll match
our donation at
50 up to a total of 2 500
so we continue to be blessed to be able
to give
back to the community here that we live
in
um so that's our our story
we feel tremendously blessed by god by
the people that he's put in our lives
and
i wanted to share our story so that some
people may have gone through something
similar
may feel like they have no hope
something bad has happened to them but
there's always a way to take
the bad and turn it into good um
my favorite scripture that i've leaned
on so much is romans 8 28
and we know that for those who love god
and all things work together for good
for those who are called according to
his purpose all right
well it's beautiful to hear you making
meaning out of a dark dark time
and blessing so many other people with
your giving
thank you yeah it's that's very touching
it's unbelievably powerful um
and you know it's interesting that um
what what that uh you know giving you
something to lay your hand to
at some of the darkest moments of your
entire life it gave you something to do
that to to not quote turn it into a
positive
but just in the middle of your pain to
do something positive
and uh because you can't really turn his
loss into a positive it's not that's
impossible but but
there can be good that comes of the the
dark hours
that you're walking through and and your
pain and you just did something really
really gorgeous with it that's so
beautiful well done
it's gotta feel great too it does feel
good it's been a tremendous
um part of our healing yeah for me
personally it's like you know
my child was 24 years old and you know
when they're little you're always doing
something for them and then when they
get big
you don't have to do things for them as
much but you still do have to do some
things but
it's like when they're gone there's
nothing left to do
but now there is yeah well thank you so
much for sharing
and high five did the you know
businesses get a lot of
bad rap for being just money hungry
grubbing
jerks high five to the two businesses
that in this story
one of them helped out the wife of
their employee that passed away they
didn't have to do that
and high five to her company for
matching the donations
up to a chunk yeah putting some good out
into the world and the truth is
that's generally what businesses do
right that stories never get so
they don't ever talk about that because
they're going to talk about and cause
division and cause other things so
instead we get the beauty of this and we
can see the bouquet of flowers it was
made
i love it uh over a a unbelievably
difficult situation it's the eve of
christmas eve
which means that it's time to say merry
christmas and it's time to stop and
celebrate generosity and that's what
we're doing today dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host
and we're taking your calls about giving
and about
receiving and my team set this in front
of me if you're still looking for great
christmas deals you can also be a
blessing
and our famous 10 sale is still going
that means that over 50 of our
best-selling books envelope systems
only ten dollars each number one
bestseller the total money makeover
approaching eight million copies now
the new quick read that hit the
best-seller list by dr john deloney 84
pages it's a couple chapters
redefining anxiety what it is what it's
not
and how to get your life back is flying
off the shelves we had to go to reprint
twice
just 10 bucks each and we extended our
discount on the starter envelope systems
and you can get them for only
five dollars right now all kinds of
goodies at daveramsey.com
and uh the sale ends on december the
31st just a couple of days away
when finally the year 2020 comes to a
close
one in the books man check it off maybe
check it off this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today on our annual giving show
if you have a giving story or a
receiving story that will inspire others
to generosity that's what this show is
about today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five faith is in cincinnati hey faith
tell us your giving story
hi dave and john how are you great
i'm in college and last year someone
anonymously donated
25 000 so i could graduate debt free wow
that's a lot of money
yeah you have no idea who did this no
idea
no it was handled through my pastor and
the church wrote the check so i wouldn't
find out
wow that's cool what are you studying
linguistics and i have an internship
with a
bible translation nonprofit so i'm
studying that side of
language learning and translation so
someone felt like that they were
investing not only into you but into the
ministry
that you're going to be doing right yeah
which was very affirming because i was
kind of thinking maybe it might be just
my plan and not god's but um
i think god and somebody else believes
in what i'm
trying to do so wow that
that you're right affirming is a good
word that's like the ultimate high five
a 25 000
high five yeah
yeah and i i don't know who it was
because i wasn't necessarily um
checking in with my church family i
moved about an hour away from
my hometown so i don't know how they
found out about where i was or how long
i'd been in college and
trying to paid off uh cash flow as i
went so
um so um i'll graduate december of 2021
and i had a question because i'll have
about 13 000
left after graduation and i want to
give it to someone else but is it wise
for me to put aside an emergency fund or
just give it all away
i think you should ask god what he
thinks you ought to do
and i think you'll have a good
indication based on two things
one is the circumstances will present
themselves to where it's
wise to do what you're thinking
and two you'll have a sense of peace
about it
okay if you don't have a sense of peace
if you have a troubled spirit about it
and or the circumstances are sideways if
both those things don't line up
then you're probably supposed to hold on
to it
okay so the only way you would release
this and i love your spirit that you're
willing to pass it on and continue to
pay it forward and
uh it might be that that spirit is
activated a decade from now
and there wouldn't be there wouldn't be
anything in noble about that
um there was no expectation of by this
giver that you
pass it on if there was any left there
was no stipulation
uh you just are unbelievably blessed
and want to continue that that pattern
and i appreciate that
um i think the intent of the giver and
really for that matter i'll even speak
for god momentarily
it was probably to make sure you get set
up and get on them
to get on this mission and i think
that's a first priority
above the pay it forward idea that's my
opinion
okay and it's worth what you paid for it
by the way
[Laughter]
thank you very much so you know but here
the the thing i always look for is if i
do not have peace about something or if
the circumstances are screaming at me
otherwise
then i or especially if both of them
aren't there if i don't have peace and
the circumstances are screaming then i
i'm going
you know i i i don't think that's what
this is for
that you know god wants to line these
things up and so
uh but for instance if you were to leave
and uh leave college and you were to
walk into a
a linguistics thing with the amount of
money paid being paid to you
that you could support yourself and you
have housing lined up and you have your
transition lined up and you got
furniture
and your utilities are set up and you
don't need any money
and you have this true this unbelievable
piece then maybe now is the time to pay
it forward
but maybe this money is to be used for
those kinds of things
and then later on you'll have the
opportunity to look back and go
i remember back when i was in college
and i'm gonna write that check
i just i i love that and i think your
wisdom is wise i think when somebody
gives
something to us that we don't expect we
instantly feel this burden that we've
gotta
now it's our job we gotta go do
something right away and there's
something about putting yourself in a
position
so that you can secretly make sure that
somebody else can give somebody else
25 000 and that takes years to be able
to earn that kind of
money to be able to give freely that way
what a gift yeah
very powerful well done very well done
melanie
is in uh if i pick up the right phone
okay kelly help me out picked up i hit
the wrong button here
thanks all right now let's try this
there she is melanie is in des moines
iowa hi melanie how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve tell us your giving story
um it's not really a surprise to anyone
that 2020 was an absolutely horrific
year
um but i went through a lot this year
that goes even deeper than the pandemic
unfortunately i started out 2020 in a
really terrible marriage
full of heartbreak and pain and just
tremendous amounts of hurt
and i was carrying it on my own and was
really secluded in that
and finally had the confidence and the
courage to confide in my sister
and her husband my name is there megan
and ben and my story is really truly
about them
once i confided in them they quickly
began helping in any way possible
in encouraging me and really just
supporting me
by both spending countless hours on the
phone with me during the darkest moments
of my life
and from moments where i was crying on
the bathroom floor to
moments where i just really felt like i
couldn't continue on
and all the time we're just really
trying to make sure that i
felt safe and secure to do whatever i
needed to do to be safe for the rest of
my life
and they also during that time converted
their basement
into an apartment for my son and i to
move into if
the time came that i needed to leave my
marriage
and i made the courageous decision in
march to leave my marriage
after continued attempts to fight to
save it had totally failed
um and at that point my sister megan
spent
well over a hundred hours between
paperwork and communicating directly
with the lawyers and helping me work
through
the loss of my marriage just countless
hours doing things for me
while maintaining raising her daughters
and working full-time
and being in a pandemic both her and ben
came out to support me as i packed up my
house and
left my husband and my sister helped me
drive across the country
i was living in seattle at the time and
we
drove from seattle to iowa in an epic 26
hour straight road trip with my
less than two-year-old son and my dog
that's like a 50-hour road trip there
yeah it was not a short trip by any
means
and then i moved straight into the into
the basement that they had constructed
for me
and the most amazing part of that though
is that they've allowed me to live here
entirely rent free
um which has allowed me to pay off every
ounce of debt i had accrued
during my fight for custody and
everything with my marriage ending
my parents and ben and megan had paid
for the lawyer's fee and i paid all of
that back to them
i've also managed to entirely fund a
six-month emergency fund from my son and
myself
and i'm well into saving for a down
payment on a house now
wow um and it's just truly i cannot even
be
more thankful so because of them they
pour the
elixir on the ashes and you were
rebirthed out of the ashes
absolutely i couldn't have said it
better myself and they've just given me
a safe place to live and
to recover and to mourn and to heal and
it's been everything i could have ever
asked for
and more a lot more and i've also
i i can't even say that that's it
because i was also blessed
my uh brother-in-law ben as a pastor of
a congregation out here in des moines
and one sunday i was in church and i
completely broke down and i was crying
in my sister's arms
at the loss of my marriage and a
beautiful couple
that i refer to only as my guardian
angels
approached my brother-in-law asking if
they could
fund me getting back on my feet
and they have anonymously given to me
and my son multiple times and continue
to do so
in order for me to just survive wow
god is going to make sure you recover
that's pretty amazing
you got people all around you and he's
seen to it that's very powerful
well done melanie thank you for sharing
that beautiful stuff
this is the annual giving show here on
the dave ramsey show
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
it's our annual giving show on the eve
of christmas eve dr john deloney ramsey
personality
author of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety is my co-host today
here on the air we're taking calls
and comments from the lobby from people
who want to tell
a giving story to inspire generosity it
could be a time you gave or a time you
received i don't care
all i care is that it's inspiring and
dustin magen
i'm matan i got that wrong dude you got
it know him well
has been with us a year and a half is on
the ramsey trusted team he works here at
ramsey
for the last year and a half has a great
giving story so he dropped by the lobby
on our debt-free stage so dustin tell us
your giving story
my giving story is a receiving story um
13 years ago my wife and i were in the
middle of adopting
our first son and um
we were fundraising for it so we baked
pies
and we're telling people hey for a pie
just give us a random donation whatever
you're led to give us so one sunday a
member of the church comes up comes up
and asks tammy questions about the
adoption and
that kind of thing and then asked so how
much do you need and my wife just kind
of
flippantly said ten thousand dollars you
know not thinking much of it and he goes
okay
next week she's delivering the pie to
him out in the
parking lot and gives gives them the pie
he hands her a folded up check and she
don't want to be rude and look at it
right there so thanks and comes in the
church
i see her coming to church she opens it
up and is just
stunned mouth open stunned
and so she comes over to me shows it to
me as for ten thousand dollars
wow ten grand i said
honey you should ask for twenty
[Laughter]
and that just sent us on a wonderful
journey that adoption
and then even in the hospital uh when
our son was born
the birth grandmother slid us to check
for five thousand dollars wow
we're like adoption's super easy
so easy then we adopted two more and
realized this not it's not
it's not easy but amazing very hard
but i i am convinced adoption is close
to god's heart
that suffer the little children to come
unto me i just
uh he adopts us you know and it's just
um
paul talks about that real clearly in
scripture and so what you and your
family have done is amazing
and for that guy to get to come
alongside you is also amazing
so you get to you get to experience your
giving by adopting
and um and you're receiving by adopting
but you're also receiving you know
you're giving a pie and you're getting a
ten thousand dollar check for it yeah it
was a good business model
yeah it's like yeah that better have
been an excellent it was not just
thinking it was not you know why
you weren't even biking paws you're
proud of come on man
come on my ten thousand dollar product
oh yeah okay are you sure are you still
in contact with this gentleman
uh no um you know he's up in church in
in anchorage alaska
and we've since moved so lost touch but
uh we became friends yeah absolutely
and the important point is they weren't
a rich family
you know they just got a little chunk of
money i just
it hold it with an open hand exactly and
that meant
so much to us and obviously will always
mean so much to us
and he's a part of our son that family
is a part of our son forever sure that's
right absolutely
what a beautiful story dustin that's
amazing yeah
wow so my challenge is when this lands
on youtube go ahead and
pull the clip and find him and send it
to him absolutely yeah i didn't want to
steal his crown from glory and mention
their names yeah
that's all right it's all good i'll send
it to him you made the point and it's a
beautiful story
yeah anytime you can assist in adoption
and we had one another hour with
uh infertility somebody assisting in
that and it's just powerful
it's powerful well done thank you for
sharing that brother thank you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you know you can hold money
with a really really tight fist
uh and it won't get away right but no
more will get in
and when you hold it with an open hand
like that that's the sign
of kindness even a dog understands that
yep come here
yeah you double up your fist even a dog
understands that i mean you know it's
just
that's a double fist is a sign of anger
in any culture
yep and when you have it when you have
it held tight like that just remember
that when you die some undertaker that
you don't know
make a minimum wage is going to pry that
hand open and take it from you because
you can't take it with you
yeah i never saw a router truck falling
a hearse never all right rachel's with
us in montana hey
rachel welcome to the dave ramsey show
and our special giving edition tell us
your giving story
hi dave hi dr john um so i was in
college and i was living at home with my
parents trying to save money in cash
flow school
and i was trying to save up for my
second semester
and i was working at a local restaurant
and i waited on a lady one day
who spent quite a bit of time uh in my
section and
i kind of got to talking to her and
letting her know my story that i was
paying
cash for school and she said you know
that's so great because i'm i'm a
self-made woman and i
i admire those qualities about you and i
was actually going to sponsor my nephew
to go to school
and he won't even register for classes
he has no motivation
so she was really happy to see all the
motivation that i had and
she said you know how much do you lack
for school and books and i said well
just six hundred dollars and so she left
me a hundred dollar tip that day which
was
more than generous but then showed up
later at the end of my shift with a
cashier's check
for six hundred dollars and said
thank you you know thank you for sharing
your story with me
um i want to sponsor you next semester
if you come show me that you got a 4.0
so she paid for that you know that 600
and then the whole next semester yeah
because you went and got a 4.0
i made sure i got that 4.0 thinking
motivation
well done absolutely so you graduated in
what
uh business management okay cool and how
many years ago was that
uh it was about gosh probably five years
ago now
wow okay cool so uh
what do you think the chances are that
when you're what do you think the
chances are that when you're in your 30s
or 40s that you're going to be sitting
in a diner somewhere writing a check
like that
oh i fully intend on it i think i think
that that was
hugely inspiring to see someone have
that kind of generosity and believe in
me and and support me in that way when
she didn't even know me
she didn't all she knew was just the
time i had spent with her waiting on her
that day
in my section yeah i i think she knew
you yeah
[Laughter]
people who go through life looking for
people to support and invest in they
identify it they can say they can feel
it
smell it yeah you smell it she knew you
she knew you better than you knew you
probably right then
well i'm proud of you well done and a
great story thank you for sharing that
very very cool open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five larry stewart was
uh from kansas city and um
i got to meet larry and i actually had
him on the show a couple of times before
he passed away of cancer
and he was known as secret santa and his
story started out that way he walked
into a diner in mississippi
and didn't have a dime and he was hungry
and he sat down and ordered food anyway
fully intending to act like he lost his
wallet or something and not have the
money
and he's talking to the guy over the
counter that owns the little diner
and the guy realized that he was broke
and realized he was running running a
game and he walked around behind him and
uh reached down under his stool and he
said hey man i think you dropped a 20
bill and he the diner guy
planted it you know handed it back to
him and larry
became a billionaire later uh in the
cable industry
and he would dress up as santa claus and
go and hand out thousands and thousands
and thousands of dollars
randomly on the streets of new orleans
after
uh after katrina on the streets of new
york after 9-1-1
he would go into areas that had been hit
by something and uh
he was wildly generous ended up actually
writing a whole thing up on his website
before he passed away on how to be
a secret santa wow and so he's wearing
santa claus outfit and he's got cops
with him because he's walking around
with
thirty or forty thousand dollars right
suitcase right there and he's just
handing out
a thousand here 500 here and just
walking around looking at people and
just walking through the grocery store
giving people money out there
carrying holding their bag out in the
parking lot and
just hands them money and then not not
even like that you don't even know
what's going on he just randomly
is throwing money around just like and i
have to believe that was more fun than
earning it
oh you bet i mean the guy was he was a
fireball i mean it's everything about
him was fun
but i mean you can't be that wildly
generous and not be fun it's impossible
i love it this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsay personality is my
co-host today on the eve of christmas
eve as we do our annual
giving show thank you for joining us
call in and tell us your story about
giving or receiving
an inspirational generosity story to
inspire everyone listening
to greater generosity more creative
generosity generosity that has more
impact
and just in general giving
barbara is with us in sacramento hey
barbara welcome to the dave ramsey show
tell us your giving story
hi dave and john thank you it's a
pleasure and an honor to speak with you
so my giving story
unfortunately begins with my my mom
passing away on thanksgiving
and she was 91 years old and she lived
an amazing life
never a burden to anyone but what i
didn't realize is that when you lose
your mom
you could feel anger and i did
and so i was fighting with my siblings
and i
felt hurt and sad and mad but one day
after storming out of my mom's condo
that we were cleaning and i was so upset
i was driving home and it came to me my
inspiration came to me
give my whole portion of my mom's ira
to my favorite charity st john's program
for real change
this incredible program lists women and
their kids
off the streets gives them drug and
alcohol treatment
counseling they can get their ged
daycare
job training and housing and they were
my favorite charity and i wanted to do
something in a big way
so i called them and let them know that
i was giving them my ira which
is going to be about um 28 000
and it made me instantly feel 100
better i was like smiling and joyful
and um so i just
that is my giving story and i'm gonna be
working with
um and also in addition
i didn't need the money thank you i am
retired
and i was like what am i going to do
with the money
why don't i give it away in a really big
way and so we're going to honor my mom
with a plaque or a bench or something
but
that's what i decided to do just so you
went back to cleaning out the condo and
you weren't mad anymore
well i wish it's not quite
not quite that simple is it it wasn't
quite that simple but i'm still grateful
and i'm so grateful for the both of you
because i listen constantly
and here's the thing i got out of debt
paid
i'm retired but i never budgeted and you
know what i'm gonna start budgeting
and maybe i can give more away it feels
good doesn't it
it does feel good it feels good to say
it to tell you the story so thank you
for that too
because it's a tough day today well it
is and
i want you to know that there are
thousands of people across the country
experiencing the first christmas season
without somebody
and that that
weight that you feel that anger that
sadness that overwhelming i don't know
how we're gonna get through this
finding somebody else to bless finding
somebody else to give to
is such a release it's such a relief
it's such a gift for
everybody involved and you may not have
gone back to that
that uh condo less angry but when you
sent that check on
man i i just i can just see you
walking lighter and taller right
yep wow what a blessing powerful
powerful well done thank you laura's a
beautiful story and
i'm um it sounds like your mom lived a
beautiful life i'm really sorry she's
gone for you
thank you thank you yeah she was amazing
well i wish both of you a merry
christmas and a happy holiday thanks for
all the work you do and for the
positivity that you send out into the
world every day
it it makes a difference for all of us
well thank you we appreciate you calling
in
and uh merry christmas to you too wow
you know there i i've often connected
generosity to gratitude and gratitude to
generosity
as a cause and effect both directions
really um
but i never think about it with the
other g word grief
yeah and um
the three could get stirred up and make
some really cool gumbo that's exactly
right yeah
grief gratitude generosity grateful for
mom her life and how beautiful it was
and that she was self-sufficient she
lived on her own she left a
ira to each of the kids in a sense and
um
you know grateful for all the good times
and all that and in the middle of that
it creates generosity and in the middle
of the grief yeah it's just there's a
lot going on there
yeah and dave i i just
i can't iterate enough i can't say it
over and over again
people have been we've been seeing the
statistics the anxieties going up the
depression's going up the grief is going
up
and if you will just stop and find
somebody to give to
find a group of people to give to let
some of that stuff
pass out of you and through you to
someone if you don't have a diamond so
okay go down
the go down to the homeless shelter and
serve soup just go look somebody in the
eye and say hey you
i want you to know that i love you go
serve soup go surf sleep for an hour and
talk go pick up trash in your
neighborhood
go do something on behalf of somebody
else get out of your head
and go be for someone else and it just
has a way of healing us from the inside
out
yeah well i mean
it's a it it's probably not appropriate
when we're talking about serious mental
health issues
and comparing them with uh this but
there's something really selfish about a
pity party
absolutely it's it's you get
stuck wondering why did this happen to
me and what did i do
and you become a common denominator yeah
instead of how can i help how can i
go make sure someone else isn't going
through this and we all rise together
with them i lost a friend of mine in
cancer about a decade ago and he was a
savant a philosopher kind of a character
uh classic i mean a redneck savant but
you know still you know what i'm talking
about
and um he said he got cancer and he's
sitting on the thing and got doc coming
in and goes look
this is bad and he goes
that's strange i was wondering what he's
gonna feel like if somebody said that
huh and he said i never thought why me
i thought why not me why not other
people get it yeah
why not me and i thought wow that's a
different
outlook because the pity party is why me
right
poor old pitiful me well you know and we
all have them i mean i can have a big
one i'm i'm a drama queen
so i can have you said it not me i can
hey hey
hey hey hey but yeah but if you're able
to
to immediately whatever problem
life lays at your feet if you're able to
back out 30 000 feet and say why not me
why not me
and we all dave we're all on the clock
right we're all on the clock
why wouldn't i but when someone says
your clock's short now you know
oh i can really start living turn 60 i
think i'm gonna jump out of an airplane
why wouldn't i well why not with a good
parachute
right yeah and somebody else with
another one so i did it it was fun it
was actually
actually all really fun darcy's with us
in denver darcy we're on the clock tell
us your giving story right quick
hi dave and john um i made the decision
in august
to leave my toxic marriage
and because of that i have found a great
place for my kids and i to move into
but we had no furniture we had nothing
moving out and i opened up to some of my
friends about
my decision to move i actually talked to
john shortly after i made the move
so hi don hey good to talk to you darcy
you too um so i opened up to a few of my
friends and just told them
they have known what had been going on
but they didn't know when i was going to
move
and within a week of me telling them
my decision and all of this they
went out and they found people to either
donate or
they bought furniture for me and my kids
they
moved everything in on the trip
the last triple digit weekend of
september
they moved three flights of stairs all
of the furniture
set everything up filled our cupboards
and our fridge with food
they filled up our bathroom with toilet
paper and cleaning supplies
everything you could possibly imagine
how are you doing now you need in an
apartment
i am actually doing incredible um
it's been so humbling honestly and
the kicker yeah the kicker is that they
loaned us their
van until we were done with the divorce
um because we only had one vehicle for
our family
and um so they loaned us their van they
paid for our subscription to streaming
services so we wouldn't have to pay that
um well they take great care of you
darcy that's incredible what a beautiful
story man that's great
friends show chance of redemption
everybody gather around here we go game
on that's right
i love it that puts us our the dave
ramsey show in the books
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
thank you for joining us dr john deloney
ramsey personality best-selling author
is my co-host today this is the eve of
christmas eve so it's our annual
giving show meaning that we are taking
calls from you
as you tell inspiring stories about
generosity whether you were generous or
someone was
generous to you and uh hey
we uh we want to talk to you the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five now moments ago john
right before i went on the air
uh our radio team
sent me a fabulous email just a minute
ago i'm so proud of them
speaking of giving our ratings on the
dave ramsey show
have gone up dramatically in 2020
obviously people need the information on
getting control of their money in a
pandemic year and so we kind of cheated
in that regard but we also was in an
election year there was a lot of reasons
for people listen to political talk
radio
and uh instead they've been listening to
us and also our
number of affiliates has gone have gone
up we've just added um
a whole bunch of them coming on the
first week of january uh we will be at
638 radio stations
uh rush limbaugh our good friend is at
uh
651 last count we had on him
uh sean hannity is at 5.75
but has more listeners than i have
because he's got some pre
a lot of premium positions and so he's
uh legitimately the number two
talk radio guy in america and without a
doubt we're number three
there's no one else in the 500s or the
400s
wow it drops down to 375 to get to
number four
and uh that's because of you folks out
there and you give
us of your time when you turn this show
on your generosity towards us
is amazing thank you and those ratings
and that popularity has allowed us
to not only become uh well one of the
top three uh
talk radio shows in america uh but also
um we're the number five podcast on all
of itunes in the world last year
with the exact same thing and so there's
about 10 million of you listening on
radio
and about 10 million million of you
listening on podcast roughly
and so thank you guys we appreciate it
it has been a
a wild and wicked ride this year
right and uh i think it's important to
note that um
with the spike of listeners in 2020 you
had one new key addition dave
who might that have been that could have
just helped send these ratings through
the roof
you know i got rachel cruz on here
pretty regularly
and then uh and she started teaching us
about humility she did
so she did a good job well played
my mom's out here for crying out loud
i'm just trying
let me just tell you it is the uh the
rock star of 2020 definitely has been
the doctor john delaney ramsey and the
uh redefining anxiety book is flying off
the shelves no
kidding it really really is all kidding
aside uh
and um no i'm having some fun i know you
are your your faux humor is just amazing
oh so we're gonna be generous here and
we're gonna take generous calls from you
guys
calls about generosity and uh it has it
you know one of the things we did do
this year is we added a co-host to the
show and so every day one of the ramsey
personalities is on the air
and that has been a huge addition all
joking and prodding and kicking
and butt kissing aside and all that
stuff but the uh
you know john's a huge addition and the
uh guys and
that work on my show work on his show as
well on his podcast and
taking live calls in the mental health
field and some of those are
rather tricky not exactly your mother's
401k
question that he gets so um but he does
have two phds and i don't
so there's always that he's doctor
squared
there we go there we go there we go all
right let's let's get out of this i
think we're
stuck here all right kim is with us in
dayton ohio hey kim
welcome to the dave ramsey show hi dave
and dr john i am so excited to talk to
you
you too tell us your giving story well
i'll tell you i am a nurse anesthetist
i went to anaesthesia school as a single
mom and i've been blessed
and i just want to give a shout out to
all the crnas out there
amen and okay this story
is true it happened to me about i would
say eight or ten years ago
well it was about three weeks before
christmas and i was in the dollar store
and i when that i put my stuff up on the
counter
and the lady asked me to put the clothes
sign
at the end of my step because she says i
have to get out of here and get to my
other job
and i'm like oh wow that's a bummer you
have to work here and then you go to
another job
she says yeah i'm a single mom and you
know i have to take care of my kids and
i said hey i get it i'm a single mom too
and so i put my uh put the sign there
and we just got to talking and i said
what what's your other job
and she said i'm a nurse's aide and i'm
like oh wow that's cool
i said well i'm a nurse and actually i
went back and
did anesthesia and i said why don't you
go to nursing school
and she said oh i couldn't do that i
don't have the money i'm not smart
enough
on and on you know so we talked for a
couple minutes
and i put my hand in my pocket and all i
had was two twenties
and i pulled it out and i said here take
this and give something you know get
something for your kids for christmas
she said i can't take your money i said
listen god has blessed me
and i'm supposed to pass it on so just
please take it
and i also had a business card and i
gave it to her and i said if you ever
want to talk
you know you can call me or email me
whatever
and i walked out of the store and i
didn't think about it again
and i bet you it was two to three years
later
probably three wow i'm in surgery i'm in
the locker room
changing out of my scrubs getting ready
to go home
and my phone rings and i don't recognize
the number
and i never answer those calls but for
whatever reason i answered the phone
and she said kim this is kelly do you
remember me
i'm like no and she said
well the dollar store and i said oh yeah
yeah
i remember you and she said i just want
you to know that i kept your card
and i looked at it every day and i
thought about you and she said i'm about
to graduate
from nursing school wow oh my gosh
the room started to get dark i had to
sit down i'm like this
is a god moment right now and then she
said
i want to know if you'll help me study
i'm like well yeah sure
so she came over you know within a week
or so and helped her study with her
for her finals and i don't know six
eight weeks later i went to her
graduation
wow
you can do it that's right i mean it was
five minutes i didn't think about it
again
but anyway i did keep in touch with her
and i called her last week when kelly
your kelly called me to see or emailed
me to see if i wanted to be on the show
and i told her i said you aren't going
to believe this but i'm going to tell
our story on the dave ramsey
show i just started yelling it's all
true
it was great wow 40 bucks in a kind word
i love it that's a good one well done
kim well done all you do is just stop
and notice people instead of being jerks
to them as you go through the line
it's not hard that's amazing isn't it
wow
what a what a hey you know what you can
do it what that'll do for somebody
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian healthcare ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the health care law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really help navigate that water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
healthcare needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you feel like you should have made
more progress paying off your debt by
now i get it
when it comes to paying off debt
sometimes it feels like a grind
and no reward here's the thing
when you try to do it on your own you're
more likely to fall back into old habits
and lose hope and that's when you stop
making progress that's why you need
ramsey plus
ramsey pluses are step by money plan
that will give you the accountability
and the practical tips you need to pay
off your debt
faster than you can on your own when you
have someone in your corner cheering you
on
you make the tough choices that get you
where you need to be ramsey plus helps
you go from
sort of to all in so you can finally
keep
more of your money to start your free
trial of ramsey plus text
the word trial to 33 789
that's text trial two three three
seven eight nine our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with new promos all the
time you get the best deal
the promo code magic word is ramsey
today's question comes from dante in
tennessee dante writes i am 27
and still live with my mom who's a widow
i want to move out but my mom's really
attached to me
how should i tell her i want to be more
independent and want to move out
dante you should be gentle and you
should be kind and loving
and be direct tell her that you want to
be more independent
and that you are ready to get your own
place tell her
with a good spirit you pay for the meal
but be honest and direct and kind and
it may hurt her feelings she may be sad
but she's gonna understand that it's
time for her
baby boy to go and those are always hard
yeah this is going to be really good for
her
because you used the word attached
and she's a widow right and um
you're uh
you're feeling a companionship role that
you shouldn't be
right i think i think i don't like that
word
and i'm with you and she is also feeling
a purpose role for him
that he needs to move on from as well
yeah he needs to get on with it for sure
there's no question about that but
for her sake the completion of her
grieving from the loss of her husband
and moving on with her life and having
her own dignity her own independence
standalone emotional state
uh doesn't need to be leaning on her 27
year old that's
right it probably is it's uh it's
probably stunting
her from going through the grieving
process the rest of the way
her finding am i wrong no not at all i
don't like that word attached
that ran all over me when i saw it
that's right and this doesn't mean that
we're not still having lunch every
sunday together
we're having breakfast and things like
that yeah but the there's a there's a
one degree or 1.25 degrees too far
of uh relational connection here that's
that's not good for her right and so
you're going to be doing her a favor
by moving out that's what i'm saying as
hard as that will feel oh it's going to
be awful yeah it's going to be bloody
yep and uh and uh because there's
because there's
it's it's too there's the roots are too
far in they got to be ripped out it's
gonna
it's gonna hurt but uh it has to be done
be gentle
direct yeah be kind calm do not raise
your voice
use lower your octave even intentionally
because when we get nervous our octave
goes up and so
um you know when you're in conflict and
so just
mom it's gonna be okay you do your chris
hogan imitation right
and uh right mother mother it's going to
be fine
mother mother all right dan is in
charlotte north carolina hey dan how are
you man
hey great merry christmas merry
christmas tell us your giving story
yes i've been the recipient of a very
generous gift from dear friends
i'm a quadriplegic so i've been
paralyzed um almost
14 years and my accessible van is
basically 14 years old as well so
i have some amazing friends from church
um
my friend charlie and we actually
co-lead a small group together
and so he drives me to group sometimes
and is aware of the the man's
in great overall good condition but
um each time i drive somewhere i
literally say a prayer just thanking god
for keeping that thing going because
i've had those kind of cars yeah so
2007 dodge you don't expect it you know
to go on forever
um and so charlie and his wife are just
amazing generous people
built up a business uh for just multiple
decades
and recently sold it and their mindset
was
just how they're going to be generous
and loving and show god's love
and generosity to people and so he told
me that
he wanted to buy a new van for me
um and just uh
two actually a month ago because it was
actually on thanksgiving wow
we uh we made that yeah and wheelchair
accessible we're not talking about a
cheap
purchase here this is serious yeah um
yeah it's a very very large purchase um
something that
um i didn't i didn't quite know what
where where the next one would be coming
from um
so it speaks to his heart uh
that he's a generous individual but
doesn't even take credit for him and
knows that god gave him the idea just to
show love
yeah towards me
that's powerful so how old are you i'm
34.
okay so this happened when you were 20
what happened
yes i was a junior in college and i was
on a missions trip
in mexico and i did a back flip and uh
injured my
spinal cord oh my god wow
oh my goodness yeah wow well i gotta
tell you it's a beautiful story
what a great guy and what a huge
purchase too
and that gives you freedom beyond money
and beyond words doesn't it
uh yeah incredibly so yeah what an
affirmation
of the type of friend you have been to
this gentleman over the years as well
i i wouldn't take any credit there
that's just i've been
uh god's been good and generous
to my mom and i um so i'm
yeah thankful for despite challenging
life circumstances that just to have a
life and people to
to love and be loved by yeah it's
beautiful man
wow very very cool good for you and a
great story dan thank you for sharing
that
so joni erickson tada has become a
friend over the years and uh similar
thing
uh dove into a swimming pool and they're
running water ant
and or want enough water in it or
whatever and um
uh broke her back and she's been in a
chair for gosh man
uh 40 years maybe
i don't know maybe more and they've got
a huge ministry of just uh
chairs yeah they collect wheelchairs
people donate wheelchairs and they give
them
all over the world and uh tens of
thousands
of wheelchairs over the years it's
powerful and she's i've spoken with her
and
she's a great speaker and great teacher
and she's actually uh
did a devotional here one time years ago
and uh but
a similar similar story to that and um
her ken her husband ken is a uh an
incredible guy but they have a wonderful
ministry
uh and it um i mean she has a unique
ability to raise money for people in the
chair because she's in one you know so
and she's uh so such a powerful speaker
and such a powerful force of nature
uh and dan it sounds like the same thing
that's very cool that's super cool man
yeah that's a good observation too
because there's something about uh
giving
it is uh i probably shouldn't say this
but it is just tougher to give to
unattractive
people of unattractive character yeah
you
you
know if dan was a whiner that's right
you know
that's cold i shouldn't say that but
that would make it more difficult for
most people including me
if you rub shoulders next to a good
friend for years and years and you see
how much good they're putting into the
world
how much positivity they are making of a
messy ugly you want to write a 50
000 check and buy him a van you can do
it that's right because it becomes an
roi in your community
yeah right it's an investment in your
neighborhood it's an investment it does
speak highly of down it really does
that's a good observation
it really does and i don't we probably
don't like to say that kind of stuff out
loud but i just did
this is kind of what i do no there's
something special about leaning into
somebody whether it's a waitress that
we've heard today or somebody at the
dollar store
they see something they see something in
them you see something in them
often people can't see in in their own
mirror reflection yeah and maybe you're
maybe the uh maybe just the spirit is
revealed maybe holy spirit's revealing
it to you
that this guy is just this is this is
one you should invest in this is one of
my kids
yeah yeah it's good it's good this is
the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
to find out more
[Music]
live like no one else so that later you
can live and
give like no one else put yourself in a
position
to be outrageously generous
on the eve of christmas eve this is our
annual giving show dr john deloney
ramsey personality
is my co-host today our
500th team member years ago
when we announced it we exploded a
confetti cannon on the stage beside him
he didn't know it was coming scared him
to death
and uh now we have 967 team members by
the way
so he started with us five years ago is
steve lind in the round on the ramsey
plus team
one of our directors of sales there and
uh he is on the
debt free stage here in the lobby to
tell us a giving story
hey steve hey guys merry christmas merry
christmas to you yeah
so like you said i work on the um the
ramsay plus team
and the team that i lead works with
churches specifically
that catch a vision and want to get
their whole congregation
into ramsey plus to start changing their
life and so
used to be financial peace university
church-wide now it's much more
comprehensive
and it's all under ramsey plus
absolutely um
so uh we um we got a call
back in the spring from uh from a young
lady who remains
uh wants to be anonymous so that's why
i'm here
um uh and i wanted to tell her story so
she got a call from her grandfather who
lives across the country from her
and he invited her to
attend his church's online easter
service right because churches all went
online back then
and she attended the service online
and every day she has a time of of
walking and
talking with god in the morning and she
was as she was doing that after that
service
um she kept getting this idea that
i want to put my grandfather's whole
church through financial peace
and what would that look like and how
could i how could i do that and
she's grown up living by our principals
she's
24 she's cash flowing in an mba
24. she's amazing
and so she called us uh she went online
found our page uh called us and we
started having conversations with her
and we even she you know she has this
this crazy idea
and we even try to do our best to
make sure that the idea that she had in
this decision that she was going to make
was the right decision for her so she
had some money
stocked away for giving and it
had it just happened to be the exact
amount that she needed to
to buy this for her church so for her
grandfather's church
so uh in august she um
called the pastor of the church and
worked it out with him
and they have about 65 of their of their
churches in ramsey plus today
and they're they're budgeting for the
first time and they're living on
living on our plan and and you know we
trusted that that that church is going
to be healthier because of it
wow powerful yeah that is so cool yeah
a 24 year old 24 year old puts her
grandpa's whole church through ramsay
plus and so there
which gives them access to financial
peace university every dollar bank sync
and
everything right yeah two classes i'll
turn this into an ad because people need
to know what this means i mean
yeah they need to know that this means
that whole that whole congregation is
going to learn how to money
handle money god's ways now that's right
when a whole congregation starts doing
that in their own home
uh the church no longer has to worry
about giving because it automatically
occurs that's right and it's going to
give a whole community of people the
same language
yeah right they start becoming each
other's accountability partner and their
own community members
and you know what's the irony of this is
is that there's somebody there
who has a 14 year old that's now going
through this
that 10 years from now will be that 24
year old that's exactly right
i mean there's financial peace babies in
that church that as they grow up their
lives are changed their family tree has
changed their direction has changed
their mentality has changed
because that's what happened to her you
said she grew up this way right
that's right that's right but so this
this is uh this is turning and looking
back and going
i'm gonna tip my hat that's right that's
exactly it
wow that is so powerful now we have a
lot of churches do church-wide ramsey
plus it's not that unusual
a lot a lot of them do it but i think
this is the first time a 24 year old
bought it for a whole church
i think it is as well i think that i
think that's pretty impressive yeah it
is special
i'm amazed wow well steve thanks for
stopping by and thanks for all the stuff
you guys do in ramsey plus that whole
team is
they work their tails off man and
there's uh they're working with churches
with individuals and through some really
challenging
things this year because uh we had 12
000 financial peace university classes
scheduled to start and then we didn't
that's right
uh and then they had to all go online
and go virtual as a
pastor friend of mine he said one night
we were sitting around in march and he
goes
and just like that we're all
televangelists that's it
so uh but that's that's you know we felt
the same way here and uh this team has
done a great job pivoting and
and still serving and getting this out
and this right here is an example of
that that whole church going 65
and the first swath that's strong yeah
that's well done
yeah steve thanks for dropping by merry
christmas you bet thank you merry
christmas
very cool stuff meredith is in
spartanburg south carolina meredith
merry christmas tell us your giving
story
merry christmas dave and to you dr john
so almost 25 years ago i
met my husband i did not realize i was
marrying him
and dave ramsey um but i am very
thankful hey i married my wife and dave
it was weird for me
only thing weird was those doggone
envelopes um
you know we we didn't buy anything if it
wasn't
in the envelope so you can imagine
uh my surprise our very first christmas
together he suggested we buy some
bicycles
um for some children that were in the
safe home
um you know very selfishly i thought
that money could
be used for a gift for me but my
husband's common sense
and his big heart kind of won me over so
um
they had like a spaghetti dinner you
know at the school that that served the
safe home and
and we had purchased two bikes that was
all we could you know scrape together to
do and
a little boy received one of them and he
was just precious and
there was this little girl charmaine um
she
received the other bike and we just fell
in love with her just absolutely fell in
love with her
um my husband was teaching her to ride
that little door explorer bicycle
and i sat with crystal charlene's mom
and
you know just she told me about their
life and how hard
you know their life had been even prior
to being in the safe home and
so for a few years we kept up with
charmaine and and crystal my husband
would go eat lunch with charmaine at her
school
and um my husband had been saving and
those blessed envelopes for this very
ugly
lazy boy recliner and thank god we gave
it to crystal for deposit
on her first little apartment and um
you know we gave her some furniture and
um
you know but all of a sudden they were
gone and
we absolutely lost touch with them and
and you know we continued through the
years
to buy those bicycles every year even
when we had our two sons we just
continued to do that and then fast
forward to january of
of 2019 um my precious husband
following very routine surgery died of a
blood clot
and so as we approached last christmas
my boys and i
really just were just aimlessly
wandering through the season
and one of my kids just suggested you
know we really should honor dad and we
we need to buy bicycles
we do it every year so let's do it so um
i agree you know you guys don't need to
buy me a gift and they agreed so
we just got to be really generous and we
bought um
a large number of bicycles and so
um i got with the principal and they
don't do the dinner anymore and any of
that stuff but
um so we went to the school one
afternoon and they had a couple of staff
members there helping us unload
all these bikes out of my son's truck
and
um one of the staff members just looked
really familiar
and almost about the same time
i realized it was charmaine and she
realized it was me
and she was just kind of looking around
and i realized just because
of her eyes that she was looking for my
husband too
and so i had to tell her you know that
he passed away
and she was devastated and i couldn't
quite understand
i understand devastation we love that
but i couldn't understand her level
from devastation and it was then
that she told me that he had given her
the greatest gift
that she had ever received and that was
of hope
wow wow wow
powerful thank you meredith what a
blessing i can't breathe
nope thank you meredith
[Music]
now
[Music]
our scripture of the day luke 2 11 today
in the town of david a savior has been
born
to you he is the messiah the lord
ruth carter stapleton said christmas is
the most
truly is most truly christmas when we
celebrate it by giving the light
of love to those who need it most
generosity takes a lot of forms today
we've been taking calls from
folks on the eve of christmas eve on our
annual giving show we're going to take a
couple more dr john deloney is my
co-host today
it takes a lot of forms sometimes it's
just a smile
and sometimes it's just an atta boy and
a girl
sometimes it's my hardest one
is not saying something and sometimes
that's really generous
i've benefited from that gift dave
or even not doing something right just
uh
not responding not responding and um
because my tendency is to hit back i
didn't grow up in a neighborhood where
we were
where passivity was taught it was quite
the opposite
so but it's it's sometimes it's a
generous act an act of great courage to
not respond
and some of you are in situations with
family members this week where you need
to
not respond you're out there and you're
listening and you're going
i love christmas because the family's
around and by the way the family's
around and
you know we all have that right because
if you think there's not crazy in your
family it probably means it's just
you there's family crazy in every family
it's for the joy of the holidays so
sometimes generosity is just
you know it's okay i don't have to have
a big debate with you on
politics this year i don't have a big
debate with you about masks
hey i have another glass of something
there
you know yes wow i'll pour
move on move on and sometimes it's money
and you know baby walking around put
yourself in a position that you're
walking around with some some fun money
in your pocket
fun for someone else where you just run
into somebody and you just have that
moment you go
oh yeah dollars really makes a
difference a thousand dollars really
makes a difference here
and put yourself in that position and
that's what these stories have all been
today
they've all been people who put
themselves in a position to be generous
because they got out of debt they're on
a plan they lived like no one else and
now they can live and give
like no one else nicole is in salt lake
city
hi nicole merry christmas how can we
help
hello merry christmas tell us your
giving story
yes definitely we had our baby girl ryan
in september of 2016 and everything was
great
january of 2017 everything changed and
that's when our daughter
had her first seizure that lasted well
over an hour
we spent the next months just barely
surviving just trying to figure out what
was happening
to our beautiful baby girl
and finally in november of 2017 we got
our diagnosis
which is something called gervais
syndrome it's an extremely rare
genetic type of epilepsy that's
essentially kind of progressive
a lot of these sweet kiddos are lost at
a young age and then after that
it's just life expectancy isn't really
known because of how rare it is
um words started spreading about our
daughter in december of 2017
and the outpouring of love and
generosity that our family received
just changed our lives forever people
had donated to
a gofundme generously people gave us
essential oils and diffusers and gift
cards
and a group of high schoolers made a
handmade baby crib
people gave us toys and gifts for our
other kids for christmas
and people offered airline miles and
gave us food 12 days of christmas cash
flowers constantly at my door just
letting us know we were being thought of
my brother-in-law even went so far as we
give us the car
so we could have reliable transportation
um
i had to quit my job as a nurse that
month to just
because we knew this was going to be our
life and so for 20
24 7 care that she was going to need um
so to receive so much during that time
of year
just just changed us changed us
who we are to our core um gave us
new perspective but with that money we
were actually able to find
get care from one of the top dravet
doctors in the u.s
which helped us learn just invaluable
information
on this horrible syndrome we were able
to get a
seizure response dog which not only
helped our daughter
but our whole family trying to adjust to
our new life
we were able to buy adaptive medical
equipment
pay bills and just stay afloat during
the
worst transition time of our lives
um we just have been so fortunate and we
we don't know
how long we're going to have our baby
girl here with us
hopefully with a cure forever but what
we do know
is that god gave us and provided us a
way
um we've never asked why it's just it's
not important to us
but we've we've always asked for the
strength
to get through and he has always always
given us that
wow so that's that's our beautiful
wonderful story
of our the miracle of our lives amen
you've got two miracles one little girl
and then one community that
hold your arms up in the desert and
keeps holding them up and keeps holding
them up
we've been so lucky wow yeah you're
blessed it's blessed and
it's a and um
here's the interesting thing to me is is
that not a single person
that has given you anything misses it
they're not they're not their lives are
not diminished
by what they gave you they're enhanced
by what they gave you and your life is
enhanced and uh that is the beauty of
this particular
character trait which is a choice called
generosity
powerful nicole wow thanks for sharing
that
i just look at these pictures of your
beautiful girl and i've got a little
girl and
whoo they were flashing them up on
youtube and uh
as we were sitting here and it's just
amazing wow
powerful stuff tom is with us tom is in
san diego tom tell us your giving story
hi dave i got a good one for you merry
christmas merry christmas john
uh my uh story is really unique it's
definitely a god thing
i have multiple sclerosis i've been a
high school teacher and coach for uh
22 years and my uh wife
found a contest to get us a mobility van
i've gone from a a cane to a walker
wrote a segway at school and finally i'm
in a power wheelchair
and as you've uh discussed in previous
calls these vans are
expensive they're 60 to 70 000 and my
wife found this contest
and you had to uh come up with a one
minute youtube
clip and uh they would enter you in the
contest and then
it'd be voted on well we had the audio
visual cut
the group from our school uh make a
video for me
post it up on youtube and we got uh in
the top ten
we didn't end up winning the contest um
the local newspaper came out and did a
an interview on me and then a follow-up
interview on how we didn't win the
contest
and i was like that's kind of weird
because you usually don't get
interviewed for losing the super bowl
[Laughter]
and i'm like well okay i'll i'll yeah
sure come on out we'll do another
interview
they did it and they posted it and about
three days later my athletic director
called
and said hey good news and i'm thinking
hey i got a new recruit i got a new
athlete
this is going to be great he's like no
someone called and uh it's really good
news i'm like
okay so i call uh the number and uh
talked to the gentleman and uh he said
hey i read your uh story in the
newspaper uh
uh the other day he said i want to go to
usa today and it was out uh
in la times it was out and so the only
paper that was left was this one copy of
the san diego local paper
he opened it up went to the local
section and there was my story
and he said i'm sorry you didn't win the
van but
i'd like to buy you a van and i said sir
you do understand that
these are 60 70 000 vehicles
he said yeah that's no problem we'll
take care of it well
he ends up buying me the van and he's
also the gentleman
who rebuilt our stadium at our uh
high school tune up a couple million
dollars we find
all sorts all over san diego places
where he
just gives like no one else that's
exactly how it works
wow what a great story i love it
it's so cool imagine having the money to
open up a newspaper and say i'm gonna
change this family's life forever
just gonna write them a chat i'm gonna
write them a check i like it
merry christmas america that puts us our
dave ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
you